partido en dos por el dolor y la
conmoción villian cliente regresó a su
hogar para inspeccionar los daños en su
casa como casi otras mil fue destruida
por los rápidos incendios forestales que
arrasaron varias ciudades de colorado
puedo comprar libros nuevos puedo
comprar muebles nuevos pero es realmente
difícil reconstruir una comunidad amigos
y una red social como esta cuando pensé
que me pasaría a mí pero el cambio
climático te puede pasar a ti no nevó en
todo el invierno de 2021 no es de
extrañar que todo esto se convierta en
fuego finalmente si nevó algo que ayudó
a apagar el fuego descontrolado pero esa
nevada llegó demasiado tarde el 90% del
condado de boulder se encuentra en una
sequía severa o extrema y esas
condiciones ayudaron a que el incendio
forestal se propagara a lo largo de unos
24 kilómetros cuadrados las familias de
todo el condado enfrentan la pérdida más
de 30.000 tuvieron que huir muchos
solamente con la ropa que llevaban
puesta lo que los duele es la pérdida de
todos nuestros recuerdos fotografías
reliquias cuotas que fueron ya sabes
indios o puede reemplazar no se puede
reemplazar
el departamento del sheriff aseguró que
las misiones de recuperación de tres
desaparecidos que se cree que murieron
en el incendio continúan y
sospechaba que tendríamos pérdidas de
vidas sólo por el tamaño la velocidad y
la ferocidad de este incendio creo que
es milagroso que si son tres fueran tres
y no cien doscientos así que estoy
agradecido por eso pero también lo
siento mucho por estas familias
se está llevando a cabo investigaciones
sobre lo que provocó el incendio el
presidente joe biden ha declarado el
estado de emergencia porque este
incendio es el peor en la historia del
estado en términos de viviendas perdidas